vienne 1913 un spectacle présenté par la
compagnie influent en scène mardi 25 mai
au théâtre
coluche un plaisir une pièce qui raconte
les quatre années d'adolphe hitler à
vienne prémices d'un drame antisémite
qui a toute la culture dans la vie
viennoise il y as en émergence en
prémice donc le pire qui va naître
c'est à dire le l'antisémitisme le plus
bêta que j'allais dire
la pièce se joue dans un décor de
kiosque à musique sur scène neuf
comédiens interprètent un total de 23
personnages différents parmi lesquels
adolf hitler
la pièce s'ouvre sur le jour de ses 20
ans le 20 avril 1909 il vient de se
faire refuser à l'académie de vienne là
la difficulté c'est qu'effectivement il
faut laisser entrevoir le führer qui va
arriver mais il n'y pas encore là il est
encore jeune il est encore idéaliste
d'une certaine manière j'ai travaillé un
personnage qui est assez froid statique
impulsif mais néanmoins très précieux
dans la manière dont qu'il a de
s'exprimer je ne suis pas ton pote
aubade à corte moi mon vote
alors comme ça tu dessines des bâtiments
pas seulement
j'étudie wagner rossi la pièce était en
création au théâtre coluche de plaisir
l'année dernière un spectacle de sortie
de résidents se présenter aux
professionnels
donc c'était important qu'il puisse y
avoir de la presse des journalistes du
bouche à oreille
voilà les comédiens avaient besoin de
jouer devant un public avant de partir
avant avignon pas ce que c'est
c'est comme ça aussi un spectacle ça se
construit avec les spectateurs
ça fait du bien aussi d'applaudir et
d'avoir eu ce beau spectacle en fait et
ça fait du bien de retrouver du théâtre
vivant avec des vrais acteurs devant
nous c'est vrai que ça traitaient d'un
sujet extrêmement grave et moins gratuit
y avait une certaine légèreté
une cinquantaine de professionnels du
spectacle étaient présents à l'avant
première
la représentation à destination du
public est programmée et 15 octobre
la fin du mois